Firoz chavin is one of about a million
refugees who made it to Germany in 2015
I said Holly Newman I felt like I had
been reborn I had made it but I came
with a heavy burden from a guru the
sofyan duomac we're Shiraz thought that
in a rich country like Germany he'd be
able to find a job straight away but two
years on he's still unemployed
integrating newcomers into the labour
market is a difficult and lengthy
process since 2015 the number of
refugees who have a proper job has risen
steadily to about a hundred and thirty
eight thousand that's a labour market
participation rate among non-european
asylum seekers of seventeen percent what
are the obstacles to refugees finding
work
Firoz had to fill out lots of forms and
visit many different government offices
the bureaucracy was new and unfamiliar
to him last year processing an
application for asylum in Germany took
seven months on average currently it's
three months but that still slows down
the process of looking for work as a
registered refugee fear us now has the
right to work back home in Syria he was
a cook but he doesn't have a formal
qualification here that's a problem as
is the fact that his German is not very
good yet come on Alan think and do let's
infinity if people keep saying you've
been here for two years already and you
can't speak the language it's true that
I can't really converse but I know the
city very well the only remaining
obstacle is the language
every refugee has a right to 700 hours
of German instruction the equivalent of
one year of daily classes but that's
often not enough to really master the
language and be able to hold down a job
Firoz took the language course but
couldn't really concentrate his wife and
their two children were still in Aleppo
in the middle of the Syrian civil war
enacted on them I very much wanted to
learn German but I was terribly
preoccupied my wife once called me at 3
in the morning
a grenade had just landed next to the
house thank God it didn't explode with
the help of a lawyer
fiona's struggled for a year and a half
to be allowed to bring his family to
Germany he succeeded his wife and
children have been with him in Berlin
for four months now that they're safe he
aims to concentrate on his career he
wants to open his own fast-food joint
and affect his German
you